let's talk about how to stop a panic
attack if you have them
you're going to be very happy you're
watching this video i'm going to show
you how to put yourself back in control
over the situation because in a panic
attack there's an intense fear and it's
a feeling of you're out of control here
are some symptoms hyperventilating
sweating
dizziness palpitations a lump in the
throat or you feel like you're
suffocating
your pulse rate starts to go up your
heart starts to pound
chest pain and there's quite a few other
symptoms now what's actually fascinating
about a panic attack is that all the
symptoms
are identical to another condition
called respiratory
alkalosis
this is a situation where the ph of your
lungs is too
alkaline
hyperventilation
sweating dizziness palpitations lump in
the throat high pulse rate heart
pounding and chest pain they're the
exact same
symptoms so that's pretty strange right
why do you have these symptoms over here
panic attack
are identical to this other condition
right here
to understand what's going beyond behind
the scenes there's something i need to
teach you
there is an effect called the bohr
effect b-o-h-r
bor comes from someone's name christian
bohr he was a danish physiologist and i
think it was 1904
he made an observation which still
stands right now in order for oxygen to
bind and be released in the blood okay
the hemoglobin
you need
co2 okay
if there's too much oxygen and not
enough co2 the oxygen will not be
released from the blood in fact check
this out 80
of oxygen is returned to the lungs
undelivered but here you are trying to
breathe oxygen right because you're in a
panic mode all this oxygen is going
through the lungs it's going through the
body and it's coming back to the lungs
and you're exhaling
oxygen eighty percent of the oxygen
because the oxygen for some reason
cannot be released and in normal lungs
when you have normal oxygen and
sufficient co2 we get this release of
oxygen from the hemoglobin hemoglobin is
just the part of the blood that's
protein that helps you carry and deliver
oxygen it's like a transport system for
oxygen and so
when you don't have enough co2
you get air hunger you're trying to get
more oxygen right that's called
hyperventilation and then what are you
going to do you're going to over breathe
right you're going to breathe more and
more and guess what you're going to get
worse you're actually going to be
suffocating i mean just think about when
a person hyperventilates they actually
end up passing out or better yet let's
say you have a party and you're the
person that has to blow up all the
balloons right what happens when you
start blowing up all these balloons you
feel very very dizzy you feel like
you're faint you're going to pass out
and that's because you're trying to get
too much air
so
oxygen is unavailable unless there's
enough co2 we think of co2 being a waste
product but it also has a very important
function to help you release
oxygen from your blood so you can
breathe so what causes respiratory
alkalosis
too much oxygen but it's unavailable
right you it's another term for this is
oxygen toxicity oxygen can become toxic
if you get too much in the presence of
carbon dioxide deficiency so how can we
use this information to pull ourselves
out of a panic attack
well
which one of these conditions can we
control can we control sweating no not
really how about dizziness palpitations
lump in your throat
high pulse rate no you can't control any
of these except your breathing okay
so by controlling your breathing which
i'm going to show you
you can
get rid of all of these symptoms
let me explain so by controlling your
breathing in a certain way
you can resolve this whole thing and
very rapidly pull yourself out of this
stress or flight or fight
mode
okay so this is what you're going to do
number one
you're going to start to nose breathe
right no longer breathe through your
mouth start breathing through your nose
what is this going to do it's going to
start to increase co2
co2 is a bronchial relaxer it relaxes
the lungs it allows for the oxygen to
finally go back into your lungs also
when you breathe through your nose you
increase
it's called nitric oxide which also
gives you a smooth muscle relaxation
effect okay so it starts to relax the
respiratory centers
all right next thing is to slow down
your breathing okay so we can get some
more co2
so we can switch from here to here it's
going to start to allow you to breathe
much better all right number three
start breathing from your diaphragm so
if you put your hand on your chest okay
and your stomach
we want to avoid breathing from your
chest so when you breathe from your
stomach not your chest you're affecting
the diaphragm
and the diaphragm is connected to
a part of the
it's called the parasympathetic nervous
system that is
rest and digest it's going to start to
relax you all right so breathe through
your nose
start slowing down the breathing
and start breathing through your stomach
or the diaphragm number four make sure
your breath is soft and gentle we're
trying to
relax the body we're trying to allow a
perfect balance of oxygen to co2 so you
can get maximum oxygen so you don't have
too much or you have don't have too
little this is why in a panic attack the
timing
is also important too because a lot of
times the exhalation breathing out is
not the same as the inhalation
so you might find that your
your exhalation is too quick so if you
start to
balance out the inhalation with the
exhalation you're going to do much
better and you can even just count
breathe in one
two three
through the nose
breathe out
one two three maybe four
so it's going to be about i don't know
between three to four seconds in
and then three to four seconds
out but we're going to calm down the
breathing all this is going to pull you
out of this panic attack very very fast
and if you can do this outside where
there's more space you do not want to
get yourself into very small spaces
because there's just not enough space
and when you're in a panic attack
everything is kind of collapsing in on
you you feel like controlling your body
is just suffocating so with this
technique we're just balancing the
oxygen with the co2 and when you do this
guess what
you can pull yourself out of this
condition too the ph of your lungs start
going into balance and become less
alkaline and exactly where they need to
be all right so the next time you have a
panic attack try this and then comment
down below how it worked for you now if
you haven't seen my acupressure
technique for stress i put it right here
check it out